welcome to this video
round two of the candidates in countyman
disk
and this is Kramnik against kayaking two
of the players that have played a draw
in round one kayaking um with this
little slightly weird repetition against
Midler and Kramnik has black in a long
book line where he is basically unable
to avoid a draw which was okay for him
it's black in the first round against
the dragon and here the second gain
Kramnik White's as one of the favorites
certainly wants to try to push a bit so
let's see what happened aha
Queens gambit accepted some slight
surprise by kayaking not one of his main
openings he has played it a couple of
times in 2000 I think it was 2012 if I'm
not mistaken I had looked it up I could
not recall a game of his and I needed to
check he has only played it like three
or four times so it couldn't be the
focus of kremlings preparation but
chronic plays d4 which is nowadays
almost the main line but funny enough a
move that Kramnik has only played once
like in 19 1989 or something when he was
15 14 years old so this is not part of
his repertoire normally suddenly a
surprise for kayaking Kramnik mostly
championed here Knight f3 96 III which
is understandable because I mean this
choice is understandable of 93 because
he very often of course opens Knight f3
anyway and
the D 5 D 4 9 f 6c 4 DC form he needs to
know this type of line against the
Queens gambit accepted anyway so even in
the move on like this he played Nydia 3
because while he needs to know this
position in any case so he just sort of
avoided any additional effort and not
studying e form but he plays it and it's
maybe the most aggressive way to go here
black has some many options one of the
sharper options is Knight f6 which is ty
Larkins choice here and white please 595
Bishop c4 so white gets the pawn back
and TM play tonight to b6 yeah here
white obviously has a choice the bishop
is attacked and he can go to d3 or b3
Kramnik opts for Bishop d3 this leads to
completely different position types this
is important to to recognize mostly
because if white comes here 96 and white
covers the pawn the black Bishop can
actually be developed outside of this
spawn chain and that's saying something
something like this is typical typical
setup in this opening it has some it
looks a bit like in a lacquer another
defense or Alekhine's defense where
black will casts a long and play f6
really somewhat sharp a sharp opening
sharp line interesting the Bishop d3
moves is really different because it
obviously controls f5 so the bishop will
not be developed and this leads to
completely different problems
what is blacks way to develop him he
played night two
before which is known the other another
possibility here is is Bishop e6 you
know I'm not an expert I must admit that
of this this opening but this is a
different possibility in case bishop in
case of night before not to blacks
liking but this is what they I can play
this is ledger to tried and tested main
move attacking the bishop which does not
want to exchange itself we should be for
and now blacks point f5 this is a very
direct solution to black some opening
tasks the fun thing is now in this
position I have like 150 games and
chrome Knicks next move has only played
in one of them he played a three now he
simply responded with a counter-attack
you know not taking on pass all this is
the main line by Miles like 150 of 151
games with this move note that the the
real point of a three are the real the
real idea is that of course now blacks
Knight is attacked and he is now given a
choice you can take on e4 obviously or
you can move the knight if you move the
knight let's say here which is not
stupid at all I mean that can play that
white is able to retreat the bishop to
f3 or to d3 I'm not sure which is better
I mean both is interesting and now we
have a position that it is that
structurally entirely different to the
position with the capture the thing is
without a3 you cannot really move the
bishop
the only possible square that is not
immediately exchanged by a knight as f3
of course and here black has the
tactical shot f4 Bishop f4 queenly form
this is the justification in a way of f5
or one point of it you know 2492 sm is
really good for black what probably
shouldn't take here but look at this
bishop it's also hanging so with an a3
y-term introduces completely Kramnik
introduced a completely new concept to
this position and this is something that
really reminds me of the candidates of
last year London the kramnik has played
many many early opening innovations and
made the opponent's yeah solve problems
over the board really quickly because
they were really so unexpected these
novelties that they had to think on him
it's not like he didn't try which was
the very often his approach in informal
years to sort of perfect long lines and
try to analyze them to do to to a
conclusion which is a very mathematical
approach and said he tried to set early
problems and then just play a game where
you have maybe some head start on the
clock or maybe irritated the opponent in
a way so that he didn't find the the
absolute best solution even if the line
is not objectively so brilliant very a
very practical approach of a player more
like the approach of a player than a
theoretician or mathematician who tries
to solve chess in a sort of mathematical
way so very good approach so a three
kramnik kayaking now had to think it's
at least he took 16 minutes for the
reply it seems that he didn't really had
this had expected that um yeah it's
tricky here obviously i mean my
interpretation is he he had prepared
this opening
maybe not only for the game against
ramnik maybe wants to play it in two or
three games you never know but he of
course had something in store against
free e phone but do you really look at
other obscure lines that are
theoretically possible a3 is a move that
is given by the computer and it's
assessed like 0.1 or something it's not
like there's there's a red flag blinking
or waving if you look at it with the
comte that you have so do you need to
check out the MU so he was probably
honest one and needed to sort this over
the board now he took me for probably
probably right --chrome Nick of course
took the night and now in Korea can
played a six yeah he six probably right
he's attacking the before porn try to
win it immediately yeah from Nick
develops the night
very sensibly and black took it on
before Jack the Queen check which is a
very important move like now
unless he wants to move the king now
which what you really don't want to do
you need to play g6 now he did that and
queen g4 so how to assess this position
right will probably win the e4 pawn back
unless unless black plays like he did in
the game where he kept the pawn for
quite a number of moves he would
probably get it back then we have equal
materia both sides as have six points
left and a very important feature of
this position is that white definitely
will have a safe King while black will
not have a safe King that's the main
difference black in this pawn structure
has a hard time to cancel short it's not
easy to do that in a way that Y does not
get a serious attack on the other hand
if you want to castlelong yeah this is
already open day finest open so that's
not so easy to do
Kathleen oh so where do you go with your
king this is a problem it's not easy to
find
naturally safe even for your king while
for wine it is very easy he will play 92
Castle short everything's nice black has
no chance whatsoever to attack the King
on g1 so we have a position where I
believe that the white side is easier to
play
maybe black is not in terrible shape in
fact this is confirmed by the computer
it always reaches near near Nico
evaluation may be giving white a little
something but nothing serious but in a
practical game it is a very tricky to
plain the computer funny enough and this
surprised me I had to analyze a bit more
deeply to to sort of understand what's
going on the computer now criticizes the
next move archaic in heavenly check this
was the caption I took on c3 I I'm not
sure and I'm not sure it probably not so
great but the overall the position
fields terribly complex to me and SSS
the whole game does I must admit
he he took there the computer suggestion
what that I really need to admit it that
I do understand the computer suggestion
is interesting the computer wants to
play Knight to c4 and the the basic
concept is ok like wants to take the
bishop and then indeed castle short so
he wants to make sure that the dark
squares are not so weak meaning the
bishop must go and this means the King
is much safer yeah the the line that the
computers is giving is an IDE to then it
wants to take
and now castle short this indeed makes
lots of sense like snow black now has
canceled it's not so clear if what can
get any attack going this also one power
pieces gone from the board and the
natural attack Bishop h6 h4 h5 is not
possible anymore at the moment the rook
is even preventing white from canceling
so this seems quite okay I agree with
that but it was very very difficult to
assess the consequences of the bishop
capture that the computer quite clearly
condemns but it's yeah it it feels very
yeah very playable I mean look at this
look at what happens played Queen d5
this was the idea to keep the pawn for
the moment keep this blockade of course
the dark squares are very weak now but
black is not going to Castle short of
course and after 92 Bishop d7 short
cancels Queen c4
yep attacking this and freeing the
knight 45 Black has very nice light
square play here and at the moment even
as a pawn now okay he will lose it back
but at the moment he even has a pawn so
it looks perfectly okay but 93 look at
what what's coming and also note the
clock x kayaking at this moment had
spent almost an hour were crumbling only
has spent nine minutes and this is of
course very uncomfortable for the side
with being being no one time especially
considering that the position is so
complicated yeah 93 are ever to Kramnik
while okay as mentioned it is
complicated Bishop c6 plate and rook
air-five rook air-five as a strong movie
notes always very
take type of move where you sort of
swing the rook over to this funny square
on on c5 gathered so that's a good move
what what is why it's idea there are two
ideas and we both will see them in the
game after the long castle here rook c5
Queen moves yeah and here exactly is an
interesting position Kramnik played the
move c4 which is perfectly logical but
he also had an alternative and there was
really surprised to see how yeah how and
the computers assessments was of the
move that I'm going to show you now and
this is rook takes c6 it's not a move
that it certainly moved that kramnik did
consider I'm very sure he played c4
yeah but he certainly considered it
takes takes Knight e4 and amazingly the
computer assesses this is very very
clearly better for white like one thorn
one point something and this is
remarkable because I mean it's an
exchange and +1 something without a
direct material regain err it's quite
quite a lot but of course look at the
position white has definite compensation
all black pawns are somewhat tricky
there are many weaknesses c5 a6 the
whole position is full of weaknesses and
white has an excellent night that is
ready to jump to c5 it's clear that and
I'm very sure that crumbling also assess
this position as excellent compensation
still it's surprising how good it seems
to be if you continue for a couple of
moves you see that it can get disastrous
really quickly and let's say something
like that rupee 8 to cover here 95 this
is just one possible line there
other ideas that can be tried yeah like
that Queen a six coming yeah now white
continues rook a one black has no
counterplay at all and it's it's
probably really in bad shape
Brooke takes c6 seems to be a seems to
be a really strong move and this is also
I guess the reason why the computer
condemns this can't this concept because
of those type of sacrificial ideas I
think however Kramnik Smoove is also
good it's not as convincing probably but
it's very tough for a human to judge if
such a move like group c6 is just good
compensation or it is really a big
advantage because he for also looks
excellent I mean you have an alternative
that is not directly sacrificing an
exchange and and look strong why a
sacrifice material yeah here it's just
like this one is a and what is like
doing now against that there's also this
idea d5 yeah black played King b8 and
gave away the pawn and this was probably
what cut Cromley can't calculated that
this is basically not able to yeah the
black cannot save this pawn really if he
tries to to to keep it there is d5
utilizing the spin and black can try
some technical tricks like that yeah it
should be fine for example but it's not
really leading to to anything anything
great here after Bishop takes f1 really
on the right line here just just a
moment I need to to check my notes here
this looks somewhat weird what I what
I'm doing here
No here white ass Knight takes e4 I'm
sorry I just had the wrong row here I
know it's Knight takes d5 indeed
Nightsister Knight to d6 there's also
quite quite strong for white it was
probably not possible to really say b6
so Callie I can played King b8 get the
King out of this
and now cronic captured on e6 and this
was probably the physician I mean he
calculated further but the position type
that he had seen when he rejected the
direct sacrifice on c6 because this
frankly speaking also looks very
promising and this might be the case
white is better but it is terribly
terribly difficult to play him from for
both sides yeah he played rook to e8
attacking the Queen the Queen retreated
to h3 kramnik spend lots of time here
probably because this was an alternative
that was very much worth considering
after rook f8 for example just one
possible move Queen takes black might
take here and it's a complete mess I
think ramnik was ok when he went to h3
it was it was a right or an okay
decision considering the general
complexities of the position I think
also that he took so much time because
of the exact moves happening next black
now took on c4 of course and here what
is why it's supposed to do the problem
is black is threatening to take now only
three and it's very difficult to play
anything else that the most that kramnik
played he took on c6 so he returned to
this idea of the of the sacrifice on c6
that he was had been able to play before
here after the
the caption c6 just vodka I can relate
he again played 94
however like was not obliged to take on
c6 he also had an alternative and it
seems that this was maybe the battles
taking only three just playing this
intermediate means with the very
important point that Knight takes e4
it's now answered by Queen d5 yeah this
is not at all easy to see but it seems
to me - yeah quite decent position for
black a possible line is c5 for example
Queen takes Queen e3 and after something
like that black it really should be okay
I mean why does nicely centralized and
all that it's equal material I don't
think that black hair has something to
to worry about him it's probably this
position where black really went wrong
he took on c6 with the pawn and after 94
we get the position that is very much
comparable to the exchange sac that we
had seen before black has a very very
hard time to defend this position very
very hard the first obstacle is right
here
and you cannot take only three because
of 95 this is not even a bad position
it's it's downright losing twin b5 and
yeah I think you can you can do you can
you can do both let's say here and if
you have the rook will join it's just
it's just too much why should the rook
on h8 be in any way better than the
knight on c5 it's it's simply too much
this is also planned
like this white can also after this can
also take with the Queen that's not not
bad at all maybe this is even quicker
know that I look of it I thought fe2 to
have this excellent pawn chain but well
d4 is not weak at all this is probably
also flat-out winning yeah okay black
cannot take on his freedom he went back
to b6 it makes some sense of course lend
some protection to the king maybe have
95 if necessary yeah okay 95 is very
obvious Queen to d5 and rook c1 this is
a possible attacking route that white is
going for yeah this position seems very
very tough to defend the computer is
already very optimistic about whites
chances and it it's it's especially
difficult to play black here in a
practical game kramnik has 30 minutes
cockiness seven minutes and note that
this is a tournament where they don't
play with an increment only with an
increment after move 60 to avoid those
those issues of rook against Luke
playing on time if you know my blitz
games okay you know what I'm talking
about
this is avoided by this late increment
but they still have two hours for 40
moves so this kind of hectic time
trouble things so PI Aachen is down to 7
minutes for 14 moves which is not
completely terrible time trouble but
look at the position he's under big
pressure and it's simply like walking
through a minefield played King 8
tonight a 6 now King b7 and night before
as mentioned this was an idea and why
hasn't the position
Queen back and now Kramnik played queen
g4 he wants to get the Queen back to e
forwards just so fantastically placed
another rule is Queen e2 to a6 yeah both
very nice attacking squares for the
Queen here awesome had to move Bishop to
h6
available and this in fact is even
stronger than what he played he kept an
edge with a smooth but this was even
stronger the idea is this direct
approach and it turns out that black is
helpless against that if you want to go
to I want to use computer evals plus
three which means that is a complete
complete knockout it's really this this
quick maneuver to a6 that black cannot
prevent computer suggests as relatively
best defense a 596 looks terrible and
even here what will get a huge attack
and the winning attack this was even
somewhat stronger but this is a very
normal looking natural move and it keeps
the pressure on this is very very
important in a practical game where
black is no one time as long as you make
good aggressive moves that keep the
pressure on you're very likely to be
helped by inaccurate moves by your
opponent because he simply cannot manage
to defend perfectly in with lower time
yeah I can plate Knight to d5 took on c6
rookie six
this makes ya make sense and in my book
yeah look at cariocans time is very much
down on the clock he tried to put up a
defense here on the six rank but it's
it's it's in vain this is just
just too strong All Whites pieces are I
in the check very very tough to defend
yeah here again a computer is much more
merciless than a human it wants to play
rook c5 however this isn't that a human
player always has problems with look at
the back rank yeah they're up there
seems there is no problem with the back
rank the computer confirms that but do
you really want to do that as a human
player you have big pressure the the
other guys on one minute and maybe you
overlooked some tactical trick and to
get back rank mated kramnik played
reform just giving himself some lift for
the king you're not going to get
checkmate it and let the other guy make
a move it's not easy at all to play one
plate h5 and now rook c5 so Kramnik
invested one move for this prophylaxis
and it paid off
h5 wasn't the best defence it seems but
yeah it's it's simply nothing you cannot
expect perfect moves with one monotone
one minute on the clock the toughest
defense seems to be something like that
yeah probably needs to go back here this
seems to be the relatively best defense
but black is still under and a huge
pressure right now can take on a7 cute
move it's it's not much fun to play but
it's not like you need to resign the
next couple of moves and in the game we
basically got to this point
h5 rook c5 yeah this is just deadly
pinon group the Aged no knight c6 it it
works nicely now for for white yeah like
a goes black took now here if he now
goes to e8 white can
capture here and this is losing the
entire look
yeah he needed to take here
Roxy sixty and whites continues to
attack while now even being a pawn up to
p.m. we have six important winning a
tempo on the Queen and you have the
Queen and went to age seven and now
Bishop g5 this is a strong move it looks
at the rook and threatens to move the
rook on f6 yes simply to g6 and the 70 m
and here Kaioken resigned the Queen
Hanks the rope hangs and this is a
decisive pin so the first win for
kramnik in this tournament
very nice fighting game where yeah he
put some pressure on kayaking early on
with this almost new idea there was one
game so technically it's not a novelty
but a three years novelty on top loaded
chess and yeah I don't know maybe it is
not objectively hyper dangerous but it
said some some very concrete problems
for kayaking that he was not able to
solve at the end it seems that maybe
this Bishop takes c3 moves is helping
much still this leads to a very very
complicated position ender and chromatic
played excellently well if he can easily
go astray in the complications you
cannot say that this was a terrible move
but it seems that this suggestion of
Knight sea form in this in this concrete
position was was maybe indeed better
getting rid of this this bishop would
have been very important to ensure a
secure King position on the on the Kings
side maybe this was really better but
this game was so complicated
complicated doing a 30-minute video on
it so almost not doing it any any
justice you could easily analyze it much
deeper if you want but I realize if you
want to know something about all four
games you're almost watching for two
hours CSL I'm not going to extend this
any longer so a great fighting game
Kramnik is yeah leading the tournament
now together with some other guys I'm
not spoiling so much him while kayaking
obviously will not enjoy this this
experience today and now in order to get
some chance in this tournament needs to
relatively quickly win a game the bad
thing about an early loss in this type
of event is I mean the loss itself is
not great but you need to realize that I
mean once you have lost one game if you
lose another ya losing two games is very
very difficult to compensate if you look
at the opposition you need at the end
you need plus four plus three to win it
and if you lose two games you need to
win like six and frankly speaking it's
very difficult to imagine that yeah
kayaking is not winning six games I
simply don't see that very very hard to
believe you never know yeah we can can
start some sort of legendary run but
still it's it feels it feels tricky I
mean to be honest the only player that
I'm always I think that is always
capable of doing or scoring six wins in
this field is not playing and that's
obviously in the world champion alright
so but a good game here and let's look
forward to round 3 which will hopefully
see similarly fighting chess than we saw
today thanks for watching